don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
guys hope you guys are well inshallah so
I'm going to be reacting to a video of a
hijabi sister who is accusing myself of
having undertone misogyny so this is a
word that certain individual sisters who
are maybe inclined to being feminist or
whatever it may be or maybe not that
they just Loosely throw this term around
very Loosely now my track record in the
Dallas team for the past 10 years would
be a big intellectual slap in anybody's
face that accuses me of having undertone
misogyny I'm working on free projects
busy truth marriage documentary and
another uh project which is an app and
all of these free projects heavily
include working with sisters I have
sisters in the panel the marriage
documentary and this app heavily
includes sisters from different
backgrounds coming to help to preserve
the marital unit so I'm let's listen for
ourselves and see what the sister had to
say of why I'm you know maybe a
misogynist a woman hater who has a wife
who has two daughters I hate them let's
see why I hate them let's see what the
sister has to say deep how not a single
one of these men are batting an island
but when I tell you it's always men who
do victim blaming when it comes to the
people who face their abuse and like I
said it will forever baffle me as to how
this guy has a platform and places to
speak I'm not a single person but an
eyelid
victim blaming I'll be honest with you I
see a lot of victim blaming from super
radical families sisters
if a man was to come and say my wife
doesn't do ABC ah but what did she do to
make her not do that
okay if a man was to come and say my
wife cheated on me oh you probably
didn't give him love enough or if you
didn't give her enough love or attention
I don't blame her this is the sickening
attitude which is the reason why and I
must say the sister but certain
individuals toxic feminists are the
reason why people like Matthew born and
many like mati will be born because of
your attitude of always talking to
victim blaming always always blaming the
man or the woman blaming the men or the
men blaming the woman it's a tip for Tat
that's why we have the Quran Sunda
that's the reason why I started a bitter
trip show not to invite people I agree
with to invite people I disagree with
and here is a statement from Matthew's
own mouth to what I was saying and he
knew I was talking about him and look
what he had to say you got the
transgressing when you come to Islam you
have a balanced way of being a true man
and not trying to go extra miles by
posting ridiculous effective stuff
which is which I'm not going to get into
detail but that's it I think there's
more to come Ali bro we all know who
you're referring to you're referring to
me everybody knows to say my name there
you go from Madness on mouth I was
talking about him and guess what on the
bittertube show I said to his face face
to face not behind him face to face that
yes I was talking about you because I
believe that and I told him to his face
which dear people didn't watch that I
would never do that if my wife's given
birth to just leave it to it I was one
of the one of the most amazing things
that I've experienced is childbirth even
though I didn't watch my wife give birth
but I was there so the point is
everybody dismissed that let's carry on
let's see what else the sister has to
say because this video actually blew up
when he posted it and a lot of people
know of his crimes he openly speaks
about it he has no shame about him and
that forward however I'm not very much
surprised now when it comes stop there I
didn't know I'll be answered you I did
not know that he admitted
to um hitting his wife or something I
that I did not know yeah now if I knew
that would have invited him yes why to
challenge him I invite people not
because I agree with them I disagree
with them there are people in the panel
a couple of them I disagree I disagree
I'll be very honest I disagree with them
but I'm not going to invite them to the
podcast because if they are seeing
something which can be detrimental and
they have some kind of an influence that
has to be challenged I'm not just going
to be like if I came there and said yeah
you're right bro beat your wife up you
go yes don't when she's giving birth
don't be there when she's needs help
cooking cleaning never help her what you
want about I was actually challenging
him so that again which is something the
information that I didn't know but even
if I did I would invite him to challenge
him but let's carry on the rest of the
podcast that was on recently I like dawa
I'm not surprised of anything that came
out of his [__] mouth
this is a hijab that's why I tell
sisters and brothers in general as well
hijab is not putting a finger around
your mouth look at the f
hijab now you might be thinking oh here
we go being petty here brother Ali you
know no no no the f word is not a light
word you're observing the hijab and look
at what you're saying and let's see why
she's not surprised what came about and
by the way let's see what did what came
out my mouth but let's watch for a
second this is how you know she didn't
even watch the podcast you watched
little Clips let's see for ourselves
what is it that she's not surprised
I noticed a very long time ago that man
has misogynistic undertones in the way
that he speaks misogynistic undertones
now let's do a little bit of a history
let's do a bit of History tick okay if
I'm not mistaken seven years ago I was
one of the first YouTubers who done a
video about talking about those who
stigmatized and look down upon divorces
and single mothers and here is a video
of that if I'm not mistaken about eight
years ago I'd done a video of a man who
lures women in and uses and abuses them
yes exposing him and the tricks that he
uses misogynistic undertone if I'm not
mistaken when it was three years ago it
was so hot that there were influences
throwing their hijabs of taking hijabs
off having an influence on our sisters
and I had to go around with a message on
my phone saying to sisters and they're
asking them to read it may Allah bless
you for wearing this hijab in this hot
weather Against All Odds your reward is
with Allah misogynistic undertones of
course yeah yeah you know I I did that
for the views and the likes you know
yeah okay okay
um oh if I'm not mistaken I was one of
the first YouTubers in the tower scene
who'd done two videos talking about
men's hijab and how a mansion a man
should observe his hijab and these
brothers who go topless on holidays but
when it comes to a sister wearing a
pinky job they lose their plot and this
very experiment that I did was actually
a little twist for a plot twister
um a a with a little twist where I would
go to men and say where do you think
that hijab is going and they'll be like
oh you know hijab she sets a job I'm
like I'm not talking about I'm talking
about a man's job and they're like oh oh
yeah misogynistic undertones if I'm not
mistaken our sisters would get attacked
on the streets I did a social experiment
of two new carbon sisters walking in the
road and how people will look at them to
raise awareness misogynistic undertones
right and even when I went to the recent
convention when he first came up I
literally told my friend I want to leave
okay she told the friend she wants to
leave why do you want to leave
if you knew anything about the works I
do anything you would know that anybody
anyone would know misogyny and my word
are total opposites opposites I can
easily come and say you know you're you
you are a male hater a man hater
to follow these words but it's people
like you you give birth to people like
Matty because you throw these words
Loosely this guy makes me feel very
uncomfortable the way that he speaks you
can tell that he has a dislike towards
women but this is the thing a lot of you
guys are blind to it and one of my
rituals made a perfect video talking
about how a lot of these people do have
a bias when they speak this whole thing
of I went to work therefore my woman she
must be giving me intimacy she must be
doing this to stop for me first
performance that is your obligation
check this out this is this is what I'm
saying to my sisters who are watching
this this is why the red pill movement
exists because of her sisters like her
who undermine a belittle and you know
who she's talking about she's talking
about my recent discussion I had with a
toxic radical feminist who was telling
men who are married that they should not
be horny they are guilty for having
hormones that make them horny and they
are guilty for asking intimacy from
their wife
this woman was seeing that we should
lower our gaze to our wives she was
seeing stuff so
crazy at one point I had to defend the
Islamic rights because she was like I'll
go 50 50. I was that sister you don't
need to go 50 50. the man has to provide
and she was like no no and I was like oh
my gosh so she here these kind of
sisters are the reason why people like
Matthew and the red people exist
Action Reaction two extremes very
brightly and openly yeah can you imagine
this is your duty work provide protect
love Etc and when you want intimacy on
the tone in misogyny you are out of your
mind system and you know what I invite
you to be to True show well with all due
respect you will have full respect I
respect every single sister's there not
a single one of them would say I've ever
ever spoken ill of them or made them
feel uncomfortable I invite you to this
show I'll pay for a taxi I'll pay for it
I will pay for your time
please come to the show and I would love
to hear you
why because I told you I believe you you
sound like a radical feminist but I will
still have you on the show if you if I
knew that you used to beat your husband
up I would still invite you to the show
you know why because I want the
challenge reviews
so that is the point but let's carry on
guys let's carry on that men ah how dare
you ask for your partner for intimacy
after you've worked no can you imagine
if I belittled a woman's hormones of
menopause
um birth yeah or on her Menses and I
said oh my gosh a man should go and get
married again because when she's on her
hormones be a menopause yes
shot of kids anymore when she's pregnant
you having intimacy can be quite
difficult and when she's on a period
this woman would lose her mind hypocrisy
and double standards but when a man has
certain hormones that make him with
studies show a sexual desire is no much
to a woman's not you know you do not
have a right to do that you are no
different from that woman that I
interviewed let's carry on it's a man to
be doing it and the women are 100
clocked out is in one of his videos when
he goes I was luring my gaze the whole
entire time I don't lost over other
women
I don't know what she's talking about by
the way I have no idea what she's
talking about I don't know what she's I
don't know what the context is I don't
know what she's talking about
and you're supposed to be doing that
whether you're single or whether you're
wiped up but yeah imagine me saying
imagine me saying a sister coming and
saying you know what in this hot weather
um we wear the hijab and I go I
I also do that anyway sister imagine she
coming to say it's so hot in this hijab
I know are you not supposed to do that
anyway sister why are you mentioning it
for I don't know what she's talking
about myself by the way but imagine me
telling her and belittling it these kind
of sisters would go crazy do you know
how hard is to wear their hijab you're
belitting it but it's all okay to tell a
man Lauren okay you're supposed
yes
this is why people like you this
feminism has creeped in and you don't
even realize and this is the reason why
I started the bitter truth show to
discuss these matters because we have
two extremes like this is the and Matty
which I've taught them I've taught them
clearly and all of those people who are
okay with giving this man a platform
yeah they're sick as well in a nutshell
guys why did I invite Matthew
I have spoken to be vocal about Messi
way before me and the job been vocal
about the red pill and Andrew take
before he came to Islam way before hijab
even had a debate and brother Gabriel
had a debate with Matty it is very clear
that we do not see eye to eye with mehdi
however and I even said it on the show I
was double-minded about inviting him do
I regret it no I don't why because I
challenged him number one when he came
and said about a woman was plotting
against her husband and Etc and I
thought to myself where's evidence from
Sharia I asked him clearly where is your
evidence from the Sharia there was
nothing if the video is there and I said
to him you still have to give that
woman's right even if you know she's
plotting that's all right number two
when it came to him not being there when
his wife was given birth I said
personally I was there I found that one
of the most amazing things now am I
seeing this so I don't look I don't give
a damn what you guys think of me I don't
care I don't do it for you I know when I
stand in front of my Lord why do I do
the better Shoe Show why do I do certain
stuff I know in Show
my witness if I'm doing it for money and
the fame and the look Allah will tell us
my witness but the point is the
following that I don't regret inviting
him he is somebody if I disagree with
him I have to want to challenge his
views he came and that's exactly what
happened now is he always wrong no there
are certain truths he speaks I
understand there are things that he says
which is wrong we understand that too
but we have to invite and dialogue and
challenge individuals like Matty and
come to a common agreement and I said it
to himself I said you are even sinful
for not giving Clarity when your wife
was giving birth I said bro you are
sinful for making people feel like that
or making them have the Assumption of
you we made that clear anybody that
watches that show from beginning to end
will see how beneficial it was when
sister Amari had her taking it on the
matter there was a discussion that was
meat so I invited Matty because number
one I wanted to question him face to
face I want to understand him better
number two if there's anything on
Islamic he says which one of the points
he mentioned I asked him for the
evidence where initially it says that
and it was that was it now if there's
certain things that he says I'm not
going to treat my guess whoever they are
whoever they are for talking to enemies
of Islam I'm not going to go and treat
them in a specific way they're my guests
in that show I will show them respect
and I will challenge them respectfully
nobody came and said methi is the guy
that we should go to no he came he had
these points we challenged them we made
some clarities and we left it at that
it's as simple as that that is the
reason why I invited him so anyone that
has a problem of me inviting I'm going
to invite many more people who I
disagree with and the Muslim ummah
disagrees with but there is a reason
anyways that's all I wanted to say about
my sisters from your undertoned
misogynist man alidawa two next number
one sisters take care inshallah and the
bitter trip shock will continue with
many more guests inshallah and we are
going to have a part two where we're
going to be reacting to some of the
stuff Matty said and some of the stuff
super radical feminist say about should
men cook a clean it's a very important
topic households brain because of this
so we will be discussing that again part
two maybe it's going to be more heated
than before if you want to be a part of
that and I invite the sister I've got
nothing against you I disagree with you
I would happily have you on the show pay
for your taxi pay for your time all day
every day please send this message to
her inshallah and may Allah bless you
guys till next time